podría convertirse en el próximo éxodo
masivo de la minoría hindú en cachemira
en esta región de mayoría musulmana e
históricamente disputada entre india y
pakistán la idea de emigrar empieza a
hacer eco en cientos de personas debido
a la creciente ola de asesinatos
selectivos de hindúes en la parte de
cachemira bajo control de india los
ataques selectivos contra miembros de la
minoría hindú han aumentado desde agosto
de 2019 después de una reunión de un
comité de hindúes con el gobierno
regional cerca de 2000 hindúes
abandonaron la región y según registros
oficiales en los últimos 18 meses 55
civiles en la cachemira india han sido
asesinados 20 de ellos ocurridos este
año
vivimos como prisioneros especialmente
desde el 12 de mayo cuando raúl but un
empleado hindú del departamento de
hacienda fue asesinado en su oficina en
el distrito de bootcamp en el centro de
cachemira luego de que el gobierno
central retiró el estatus de genia
autonomía a cachemira a los ciudadanos
resguardados en sus casas por el temor
de la creciente violencia les preocupa
que se repita el éxodo de más de 75.000
personas que siguió estallido de
violencia en 1989 incitado por grupos
musulmanes separatistas la principal
organización de la minoría hindú que en
el éxodo de fines de los 80 decidió
permanecer en cachemira hizo una
petición al jefe de justicia regional
solicitando mayor protección a las
minorías religiosas el gobierno de la
región ha establecido varios
asentamientos de tránsito con el
objetivo de acomodar a aquellos hindúes
que no tienen alojamiento bajo
protección en cachemira